all right we are now live for another of
the story time with Sandler I'm gonna
read for you some of my favorite short
stories these are very short stories
indeed this time uh by HP Lovecraft I
wanted to do the cats of olar because it
is actually one of my favorite stories
by Lovecraft and it also has to do with
I think many of you know I I care about
cats quite a bit but I saw how short it
was and I thought well maybe we need to
do a double header of sorts so we also
have the other gods which is set in the
same narrative Universe we're not going
to do the uh uh unknown cadth you know
dream stuff because that's a much longer
story so what I do in all these sessions
is I read the story and I tell you about
what it is that I particularly like
about it how I got into it and then um
you know we do some Q&A some comments we
have some conversation here you can
leave whatever you would like to in the
chat and um you know usually we wind up
spending a good bit of time in these
sessions so with no further Ado let's
start with HP lovecrafts the cats of
ulthar it is said that in althar which
lies beyond the river Sky no man May
kill a cat and this I can verily believe
as i gaze upon him who sth purring
before the fire for the cat is cryptic
and close to strange things which men
cannot see he is the soul of antique
egyptus and bearer of tales from
forgotten cities in meroy and ofier he
is the the kin of the Jungle Lords and
heir to the secrets of Hy and Sinister
Africa the Sphinx is his cousin and he
speaks her language but he is more
ancient than the Sphinx and remembers
that which she hath
forgotten in althar before ever the
Burgesses forbade the killing of cats
there dwelt an old cter and his wife who
delighted to trap and slay the cats of
their neighbors why they did this I know
not save that many hate the voice of The
Cat in the night and take it ill that
cats should run stealthily about yards
and gardens at Twilight but whatever the
reason this old man and woman took
pleasure in trapping and slaying every
cat which came near to their Hub and
from some of the sounds heard after dark
many villagers fancied that the manner
of slaying was exceedingly peculiar but
the villagers did not discuss such
things with the old man and his wife
because of the habitual expression on
the withered faces of the two and
because their Cottage was so small and
so Darkly hidden under spreading Oaks at
the back of a neglected
yard in truth much as the owners of cats
hated these odd folk they feared them
even more and instead of berating them
as brutal assassins merely took care
that no cherished pet or Mouser should
stray toward the remote h under the dark
trees
when through some unavoidable oversight
a cat was missed and sounds heard after
dark the loser would lament impotently
or console himself by thaning Fate it
was not one of his children who had thus
vanished for the people of alar were
simple and knew not when it is once it
is all cats first
came one day a caravan of strange
Wanderers from the south entered the
narrow cobbled streets of ulthar dark
Wanderers they were and unlike the other
roving folk who passed through the
village twice every year in the
marketplace they told fortunes for
silver and bought gay beads from the
merchants what was the land of these
Wanderers none could tell but it was
seen that they were given to strange
prayers and that they had painted on the
sides of their wagons strange figures
with human bodies in the heads of cats
Hawks Rams and lions and the leader of
the Caravan wore a headdress with two
horns and a curious disc betwix the
horns there was in this singular Caravan
a little boy with no father or mother
but only a tiny black kitten to
cherish the plague had not been kind to
him yet had left him this small furry
thing to mitigate his sorrow and when
one is very young one can find great
relief in the Lively antics of a black
kitten
so the boy who the dark people called
Menace smiled more often than he wept as
he sat playing with his graceful kitten
on the steps of an oddly painted
Wagon on the third morning of The
Wanderer stay in ulthar Menace could not
find his kitten and he as he sobbed
aloud in the marketplace certain
villagers told him of the old man and
his wife and of sounds heard in the
night and when he heard these things his
sobbing gave place to meditation and
finally to prayer he stretched his arms
towards the Sun and prayed in a tongue
no villager could understand though
indeed the villagers did not try very
hard to understand since their attention
was mostly taken up by the sky and the
odd shapes the clouds were assuming it
was very peculiar but as the little boy
uttered his petition there seemed to
form overhead the shadowy nebulous
figures of EXO IC things of hybrid
creatures crowned with horn flanked
discs nature is full of such Illusions
to impress the
imaginative that night The Wanderers
left uar and were never seen again and
the householders were troubled when they
noticed that in all the village there
was not a cat to be found from each
Hearth The Familiar cat had vanished
cats large and small black gray striped
yellow and white old cranon the burgo
master swore that the dark folk had
taken the cats away in Revenge for the
killing of menace's kitten and cursed
the Caravan and the little boy but nith
the lean notary declared that the old
Cotter and his wife were more likely
persons to suspect for their hatred of
cats was Notorious and increasingly bold
still no one Durst complain to the
Sinister couple even when little otel
the inkeeper son vowed that he had at
Mid Twilight seen all the cats of ulthar
in that accursed yard under the trees
pacing very slowly and solemnly in a
circle around the cottage too a breast
as if in performance of some right
unheard of right of beasts the villagers
did not know how much to believe from so
small a boy and though they feared that
the evil par had Charmed the cast of
their death they preferred not to tride
the old Cotter until they had met him
outside his dark and repellent
yard so althar went to sleep in vain
anger and when the people awake at dawn
behold every cat was back at his
accustomed Hearth large and small black
gray striped yellow and white none was
missing very sleek and fat did the cats
appear and sonorous with purring
content the citizens talked with one
another of the affair and marveled not a
little old cranon again insisted it was
the dark folk who had taken them since
cats did not return alive from the
cottage of the Ancient Man and his wife
but all agreed on one thing that the
refusal of all the cats to eat their
portions of meat or drank their saucers
of milk was
exceedingly curious and for two whole
days the Sleek lazy cats of olar would
touch no food but only do by the fire
or in the
sun it was fully a week before the
villagers noticed that no lights were
appearing at dusk in the windows of the
cottage under the trees then the lean
nith remarked that no one had seen the
old man or his wife since the night the
cats were away in another week the bergo
master decided to overcome his fears and
call at the strangely silent dwelling as
a matter of Duty though in doing so he
was careful to take with him Shang the
blacksmith and THU the cutter of stone
and as
Witnesses and when they'd broken down
the frail door they found only
this to cleanly picked human skeletons
on the earth and floor and a number of
singular beetles crawling in the shadowy
corners there was subsequently much talk
among the Burgesses of ulthar zath the
coroner disputed at length with nil the
lean notary and crannon and Shang and
thul were overwhelmed with questions
even little otel the inkeeper son was
closely questioned and given a sweet
meat as a
reward they talked of the old Cotter and
his wife of the Caravan of dark
Wanderers of small Menace and His black
kitten of the prayer of Menace and of
the sky during that prayer of the doings
of the cat on the night the Caravan left
and of what was later found in the
cottage under the dark trees in the
repellent
yard and in the end the the Burgesses
pass that remarkable law which is told
of by traitors in ho and discussed by
Travelers in near namely that an orar no
man May kill a cat so that is the very
short story The Cats of ulthar by HP
Lovecraft let's turn now since we're
doing a double header to the next story
set in the same narrative universe the
other
gods so the other gods by HP
Lovecraft at top the tallest of Earth's
Peaks dwell the Gods of Earth and suffer
no man to tell that Heath looked upon
them lesser Peaks they once inhabited
but ever the men from the plains would
scale the slopes of rock and snow
driving the gods to higher and higher
mountains till now only the last remains
when they left their older Peaks they
took with them all signs of themselves
save once it is said when they left a
carven image in the face of the mountain
which they called
nech but now they have betaken
themselves to unknown kth in the cold
waste where no man Treads and are grown
Stern having no higher Peak where to to
flee at the coming of men they are grown
Stern and where once they suffered men
to displace them they now forbid men to
come or coming to
depart it is well for men that they know
not of cadth in the cold
waste else they would seek in
injudiciously to scale
it sometimes when Earth's gods are
homesick they visit in the still night
the Peaks where once they dwelt and weep
softly as they try to play in the olden
way on Old on remembered slopes men have
felt the tears of the Gods on white kept
th though they have thought it rain and
have heard the size of the Gods and the
plain of dawn Winds of larion in Cloud
ships the gods are want to travel and
wise cotters have legends that keep them
from certain High Peaks at night when it
is cloudy for the gods are not as
lenient as of
old in alar which lies beyond the river
Sky once dwelt an old man of avid to
behold the Gods of Earth a man deeply
learned in the seven cryptical books of
Hassan and familiar with the p pannic
manuscripts of distant and Frozen lar
his name was barai the wise and the
villagers tell of how he went up a
mountain on the night of the strange
Eclipse barai knew so much of the gods
that he could tell of their comings and
goings and guessed so many of their
secrets that he was deemed half a God
himself it was he who wisely advised the
Burgesses of althar when they passed
their remarkable law against the slaying
of cats and who first told the young
priest AEL where it is that black hats
go at midnight on St John's Eve barzi
was learned in the lore of Earth's gods
and had gained a desire to look upon
their faces he believed that his great
secret knowledge of gods could Shield
him from their wrath so resolved to go
up to the summit of high and Rocky
hagath CLA on a night when he knew the
gods would be
there hagath Claw is far in the Stony
desert Beyond ha for which it is named
and Rises Like a Rock statue in a silent
Temple around its peak The Mists Play
Always mournfully for Mists are the
memories of the Gods and the gods loved
hath claw when they deal dwelt upon it
in the old days often the Gods of Earth
visit hacla in the ships of cloud
casting pale Vapors over the slopes as
they dance reminiscently on the summit
under a clear Moon the villagers of Haag
say it is ill to climb hagath Claw at
any time and deadly to climb it by night
when pale Vapors hide the summit and the
moon but barai heeded them not when he
came from neighboring uar with the young
priest atel who is his disciple atel was
only the son of an inkeeper and was
sometimes afraid but bari's father had
been a landgrave who dwelt in an ancient
castle so he had no common Superstition
in his blood and only laughed at the
fearful
cotters barzi and AEL went out of Haag
into the Stony desert despite the
prayers of peasants and talked of
Earth's Gods by their campfires at night
many days they traveled and from afar
saw a lofty ha claw with his orol of
mournful Mist on the 13th day they
reached the Mountain's lonely base and
otel spoke of his fears but arai was old
and learned and had no fears and so led
the way boldly up the slope that no man
had scaled since the time of sansu who
is written of with fright in The Moldy
pactic
manuscripts the way was Rocky and made
perilous by chasms Cliffs and falling
Stones later it grew cold and snowy and
barai a often slipped and fell as they
hewed and plotted upward with staves and
axes finally the air grew thin and the
sky changed color and the climbers found
it hard to breathe but still they toiled
up and up marveling at the strangeness
of the
scene and uh thrilling at the thought of
what would happen on the summit when the
moon was out and the pale Vapors spread
around for three days they climbed
higher and higher and higher towards the
roof of the world then they camped to
wait for the cloud CL ing of the
moon for four nights no clouds came and
the moon Shone down cold through the
thin mournful Mists around the silent
Pinnacle then on the fifth night which
was the night of the full moon barai saw
some dense clouds far to the
North and stayed up with atel to watch
them draw
near thick and Majestic they sailed
slowly and deliberately onward ranging
themselves round the peak high above the
waters and hiding the moon and the
summit from view for a long hour the
Watchers gazed while the vapor swirled
and the screen of clouds grew thicker
and more Restless barai was wise in the
lore of Earth's gods and listened hard
for certain sounds but AEL F felt the
chill of the vapors and the awe of the
night and feared much and when barai
began to climb higher and Beck and
eagerly it was long before atel would
follow so thick were the vapors that the
way was hard and though AEL followed on
at last he could scarce see the gray
shape of barai on the dim slope above in
the clouded Moonlight barai forged very
far ahead and seemed despite his age to
climb more easily than atel fearing not
the steepness that began to grow too
great for any save a strong and
dauntless man nor in at a wide black at
wide black chasms that AEL scarce could
leap and so they went up wildly over
rocks and Gulf slipping and stumbling
and sometimes awed at the vastness and
horrible Silence of Bleak ice Pinnacles
and mute Granite
steps very suddenly barai went out of
ael's sight scaling a hideous Cliff that
seemed to bulge outward and block the
path for any climber not inspired of
Earth's gods otel was Far Below and
planning what he should do when he
reached the place when curiously he
noticed that the light had grown strong
as if the cloudless peak and moonlit
meeting place of the gods were very near
and as he scrambled on towards the
bulging cliff and Litt Sky he felt fears
more shocking than any he had known
before then through the high Mists he
heard the voice of unseen barai shouting
wildly in Delight I have heard the gods
I have heard Earth's Gods singing in Rev
on hath claw the voices of Earth's gods
are known to barai the prophets The
Mists are thin and the Moon is bright
and I shall see the gods dancing wildly
on hagath claw that they loved in youth
the wisdom of barai hath made him
greater than Earth's gods and against
his will their spells and barriers are
as not barai will behold the gods the
proud Gods the secret Gods the Gods of
Earth who spurn the sight of
man ATL could not hear the voices barai
heard but he was now close to the
bulging cliff and scanning it for
footholds then he heard bari's voice
grow shriller and louder The Mists are
very thin and the moon cast Shadows on
the slope the voices of Earth's gods are
high and wild and they fear the coming
of barai the wise who is greater than
they the moon's lights flickers as Earth
Gods dance against it I shall see the
dancing forms of the gods that leap and
Howl in the Moonlight the light is
dimmer and the gods are
afraid while spari was shouting these
things AEL felt a spectral change in the
air as if the laws of Earth were bowing
to Greater laws for though the way was
steeper than ever the upward path was
now grown fearsomely easy and the
bulging Cliff proved scarce an obstacle
when he reached it and slid perilously
up its convex face the light of the Moon
had strangely failed and as atel plunged
upward through the Mists he heard barai
the wi shrieking in the
shadows the Moon is dark and the gods
dance in the night there is Terror in
the sky for upon the moon hath sunken
Eclipse foretold in no books of men or
of Earth's Gods there is unknown Magic
on claw for the screams of the
frightened gods have turned to laughter
and the slopes of ice shoot up endlessly
into the black Heavens wither I am
plunging hey hey at last in the dim
light I behold the Gods of Earth and now
atel slipping dizzily up over
inconceivable Steeps heard in the dark a
loome laughing mixed with such a cry as
no man else ever heard save in the fagon
of unrelatable nightmares a cry wherein
reverberated the horror and anguish of a
haunted lifetime packed into one
atrocious moment the other gods the
other gods the gods of the outer hells
that guard the feeble Gods of Earth look
away go back do not see do not see the
Vengeance of the infinite abysses that
curse of that damnable pit merciful Gods
of Earth I am falling into the
sky and as
shut his eyes and stopped his ears and
tried to jump downward against the
frightful Pole from unknown Heights
there resounded on hagath claw that
terrible peel of Thunder which awakened
the good cters of the Plains and the
honest Burgesses of Haag and near and
olar and caused them to behold through
the C clouds that strange eclipse of the
Moon that no book ever predicted and
when the moon came out at last was safe
on the lower Snows of the mountain
without sight of Earth's gods or of the
other
gods now it is told in The Moldy pactic
manuscripts that sansu found not but
wordless ice and rock when he climbed
hath claw and the Youth of the world yet
when the men of ulthar and near and Haag
crushed their fears and scaled that
haunted steep by day in search of barai
the wise they found Raven in the naked
Stone of the summit a curious and
cyclopian symbol 50 cubits wide as if
the rock had been Riven by some Titanic
chisel and the symbol was like to one
that learned men have discerned in those
frightful parts of the pactic
manuscripts which are too ancient to be
read this they
found barai the wise they never found
nor could the holy priest AEL ever be
persuaded to pray for his Soul's
Repose moreover to this day the people
of ulthar and nearer and Haag fear
eclipses and Pray by night when pale
Vapors hide the Mountaintop and the moon
and above the M on hath claw Earth's
Gods sometimes dance reminiscently for
they know they are safe and love to come
from unknown cth in ships of cloud and
play in the olden way as they did when
Earth was new and men not given to the
climbing of inaccessible
places so there we have two quite short
stories by HP Lovecraft and these are
not part of his let's call it Cosmic
horror tales that people know as the
cthulu Mythos and you know I think he's
most famous for this is from an earlier
period where he was under the influence
of uh d and was writing things were more
Fantastical right I you I think you
could say that there is horror involved
in these but they're more fantasy
stories the first is almost a fairy tale
isn't it about the
cats this one is a Twist story about
human beings that are going to one you
know Al to hubristically the other one
reluctantly following along going to see
something that they're not supposed to
see because they are bold and have uh
the the power to you know contravene the
will of the the gods but then they find
out there are other gods Gods more
powerful Gods perhaps more ancient gods
who protect the Earth's Gods so I I've
always loved these two stories myself I
read them I think I want to say as a
middle schooler um probably in sixth or
seventh grade not in anything that I was
assigned but because I checked out a
book from the library of HP lovecrafts
short stories and I'm not sure what put
into my head to check them out um but I
really did
enjoy uh reading them and I'll say one
other thing before I look at some of the
questions and comments it was a very
nice surprise to me to find out uh with
both of my kids because I never really
try to push them oh you should read this
you should read this I let them come to
things on their own that both of them on
their own
independently came to start reading and
be interested in the stories of HP
Lovecraft
so all right so um
who framed the Socratic method says I
think he returns well atel certain
certainly returns um Quinn wanted to say
thanks for your content on the master
servant dialectic um no that's good
that's that's Hegel not not really
connected to
Lovecraft
um so to this duny fantasy in cth yeah
Oh you mean HP Lovecraft returns to This
Not That barai returns because barai is
gone you're not getting him back any
more than you're getting the little
black kitten back yeah he he has the
dream waste of unknown katth which is a
much longer story and they're all set
within the same narrative universe as I
mean you can tell very very easily by
the uh characters that are being
mentioned here by the events that are
crisscrossing by the locations and stuff
like that so I'd be curious to see what
other people make of these stories if
you've read them
before um you know it's a kind of a
departure for Lovecraft these are among
some of my favorite stories this this
idea of you
know the sky opening up and as he puts
it um the
laws changing let me get back to that
passage
um and then you know going up into the
sky right that is here we
go as if the laws of Earth were bowing
to Greater laws not just alternate laws
but greater laws there's a revelation
here of how things truly are and this is
Lovecraft in right Lovecraft has this uh
remark that he makes uh about uh if we
really knew how things stood and I'm
paraphrasing here we would be just
terrified uh you know witnessing how
things really are and he's got another
story I don't remember the name of it
offand where somebody invents a machine
that will let you see all the beings
around you and you know if we're like
big boosters of science we'd be like oh
that's amazing we can see much further
than we did before and uh for Lovecraft
it drives the person the scientist
insane with with Terror because he sees
all of these creeping crawling not
fitting neatly into our ukian geometry
Universe things that are all around us
and you know it's interesting if you
think about that
thematic um think about how it must have
been for people to realize that bacteria
are everywhere you know gross germs you
know uh for us we kind of were like H
yeah okay we know that from biology
class but earlier Generations had to
adjust to that or think about the shock
involved in realizing that the Earth not
only is not the center of the solar
system but is just a tiny little blip in
the universe itself that's one of the
key I don't want to say ideas feelings
feelings is a better term that Lovecraft
himself is very much responding to and
influenced by uh Quinn says uh about the
uh Master Slave dialectic I meant it
saved me with an assignment recently
definitely love the fantasy Thriller
okay that's a good one yeah fantasy
Thriller not fantasy horror fantasy
Thriller with a Twist to each one right
uh aspects of these and you know does
that twist technique work as well in the
present where we're kind of accustomed
to it I think you know for me
it it still does but it doesn't work
with every author I mean if you've read
Oh Henry you know that he loves he's an
another American
Author loves to always have like a Twist
at the end gasant a French author is
like that as well and um sometimes it
seems a little contrived or a little bit
trite in these stories and perhaps
that's because of the structure of the
stories um or perhaps it's just because
Lovecraft is a great writer
at at times um it really works you know
the and I think it works better in the
other gods than it does in the cats of
olar in part because we're working with
changing the
very structure of reality the universe
that we're in Quinn says kind of
reminded me of Po yeah you know it's
interesting you bring that up um
Lovecraft is a big fan of Poe and
Stephen King at one point and I don't
remember where he says this he says we
had Po and po be gets Lovecraft and I
Stephen King am influenced by Lovecraft
and B po you know tracing out a kind of
genealogy of imaginative horror because
we can talk about unimaginative horror
you know we can talk about things that
you know I was talking about this with
my students because we read Mary Shell's
Frankenstein and when you look at the
depictions of Frankenstein
Frankenstein's monster as this stupid
brute that just goes around afraid of
fire right um you know that can be
comedy fodder for Scooby-Doo or Abbott
and Castello but it's not it's not
really getting at you anymore when you
read Mary Shell's Frankenstein and you
think about the important philosophical
questions that are being raised in the
interactions between the creature and
Frankenstein himself and you've got a
very intelligent
creature um who's R Milton and Plutarch
and you know uh other people Sorrows of
young verer right there you've got the
potential for
something greater something richer and I
think that's part of what you can say
with that genealogy you know Stephen
King
um especially in his earlier writings is
is quite a great horror author and you
know is influenced by Lovecraft who is
influenced by po so yeah I think I think
there is a uh
poetic influence going on there um any
other things that that you want to say
ask
about when it comes to these
stories I mean for me the saddest part
is poor Menace right I mean the kid does
get revenge but he loses this you know
this little kitten that is his one
consolation his one friend in the world
and that's what's needed to get the plot
going right and it doesn't it doesn't
make things better for Menace that he
attains
Revenge all right so who framed the
Socratic method do you think the
revelation of Terror is informed by his
science journalism and
worldview for me it's a comment on
device on tragedy device like de x mcka
uh or limits of humism in modernity okay
so
um deos X mcka is actually an
unsuccessful tragedy device right it's
uh something that Aristotle himself
criticizes in the Poetics so we don't
want something that's a deis x mcka
which is just a god dropped down from on
high to the stage to resolve some some
irresolvable problem but the limits of
humanism yeah I mean Lovecraft is
definitely somebody who thinks that
human beings are
not um the the central show in reality
as as we C and when you look at the
cthulu Mythos right you got this vast
you know billions of years kind of
Panorama and all sorts of uh you know
great old ones you got a uh a blind and
stupid uh you know azoth at the center
of the universe piping away well
actually he's just churning away I think
if I remember right there's Pipers
around him um you know we're we're like
nothing compared to these things you
know there's been other races here in
the the world Earth as we know it and
they've you know died or maybe didn't
completely di the shaggoths are still
there you know in in Antarctica um
waiting to be rediscovered so I mean
that's definitely part of
lovecraft's um point of view isn't it
and you know it's interesting because we
we just we talked about po Lovecraft
Stephen King somebody else who's clearly
very influen by Lovecraft and has taken
some of these ideas further is Thomas
lagati right who uh is a current well so
is King uh currently living horror
author um very imaginative but who's
written about this sort of stuff in a
non-fiction book uh conspiracy against
the human race which we covered in the
world's of speculative fiction series
just a few months
ago um Bruno says I really enjoy the
quote in in the Tomb the Learned man
knows there's no clear distinction
between the real and the
unreal yeah I mean there is science
right for Lovecraft um so we can carry
out
scientific work and you could say well
the things that we study in science
those are real right or at least the
measurements we take of them are real
but most of the human beings in love
lovecraft's Universe are not scientists
you know they're they're ordinary folk
and some of them are involved in Cults
to bring about the great old ones now
not so much in these these fantasy
stories but with Lovecraft and the
larger horror stuff um yeah and and
there's also and this is something that
Lovecraft thought about a lot and talked
with his fellow uh writers quite a bit
this poetic production of of um stories
of narratives of characters of in
insights and and Lovecraft in
supernatural horror in literature
actually says it's not really so much
about um what we would call the level of
the content it's the atmosphere that you
produce and this is one way that we can
like distinguish these stories the ones
that we just looked at these uh they're
often called D aayan because he's under
the influence of Lord D um these fantasy
stories from the stories of Cosmic
horror although you know the other gods
is kind of leaning into that um it's a
different atmosphere that is being
generated in them and I would even say
maybe there's different sub atmospheres
created across lovecrafts horror stories
as well you know so that the thing on
the doorstep is not quite the same
atmosphere as um the call of cthulu you
know or um
mountains of Madness or you know DWI
horror stuff like that
right so Matt Gilbert says I appreciate
the way Lovecraft explores deep time in
his work so yeah deep time this is this
is kind of a a recently articulated
concept but I guess the idea has been
around for quite a while um and this is
part of what what you know made a lot of
people in modernity who are more
traditional uh want to reject things
like uh um the not you know fossils
Evolution all these these sorts of
things about uh the the scientific view
of the world you know we human beings
and our cultures especially have been
around for just like a tiny tiny little
part of the timeline
right and I mean it's it's really
interesting when you think of this I I
sprung this on one of my classes just
the other day part of Earth's history
right
included a time when you couldn't even
have fire you could have hot stuff you
know the core was molten still is thank
God because otherwise we'd be screwed um
you could have volcanoes you could have
all sorts of things but you couldn't
actually have fire until you had enough
oxygen in the atmosphere to have that
and that required that there be plants
uh and other you know uh organisms
taking in carbon dioxide producing
oxygen and a waste product until you had
that you couldn't even really have this
thing that that our ancestors years and
years back and culture after culture
after culture have taken not just as a
reality of their lives but as a primal
element of the existence of things so
you
know part of part of the promise of deep
time in lovecrafts works is that um we
don't even really understand the
chronology of things you know it just
goes way way back and and Lovecraft you
know uses language to try to convey this
you know he loves the word eons you know
uh he loves talking about these
incredibly
old um
cyclopian uh cities or ruins or or
things like that that we could we could
participate in and you know again you're
getting kind of a hint of that in this
um story the other gods I would say
um all right who framed the Socratic
method I like the irony of from Beyond
being both body horror and Cosmic horror
with a line about philosophy and science
potent potentially destroying reason
Lovecraft had wit and irony like uh Po
and wild so Oscar wild yeah and you know
the lovecraftian view on things I'm not
going to say it's derived from nche but
nche in his works from the birth of
tragedy onward this is one of the
central themes of his works that hey
it's so cool we have modern science but
modern science in revealing to us the
world both uh undercuts you know older
traditional ways of understanding things
and even comes to undercut
itself and this is the the problem of
neoism that gets um raised as what he
calls the the problem of the coming
Century he he lives to see in an you
know in an insane asylum and then dies
shortly afterwards the the the new
century the
1900s that were no longer in um and and
N thinks that the development and spread
of the Sciences plays a a central role
in that and so like destroying reason um
destroying rationalism destroying our
faith in human reason um and you can say
well how the hell does something that is
coming from reason gonna do that well
this is one of the paradoxes that you
know n and and Lovecraft and other
people are bringing out and I would even
say you know going back to edar Allen
Poe you read that story the Imp of the
perverse right um and uh there you know
so we're talking now the the early
1800s um that's a very interesting essay
isn't it all right Quinn says my
schooling is in archaeology primarily I
love the combination between material
history and philosophical practice not
too relevant but reminded me of deep
time discussion around fire tech yeah
you know to to take this into a
different direction
uh I often tell my students you know
when we start a philosophy class you
have been doing philosophy your whole
life you just been doing it without
realizing it was called that and you've
probably done it in slipshod ways you
know and you might still be doing that
later on and there's plenty of people
out there doing philosophy with a
capital P who are are doing so in kind
of slip shot dogmatic ways as well um
but you can't you you you as much as you
try to like confine point of view to I'm
just going to do science you can't
science is inextricably connected up
with philosophy there's no way around it
you know and so now the part of the
problem is okay so well I better study
philosophy well there's so much damn
stuff out there that you're never going
to be able to study all of it and the
more time that you do explicitly study
philosophy the less time you have for
doing your actual day job you know and
vice versa right so we're always kind of
cobbling together stuff on on the Fly
um so Matt has another question um do we
know which if any philosophers influence
Lovecraft I'm aware of an essay he wrote
about neoism and I think his
atheism yeah and and he's not an he's
not an atheist in the way like the the
new atheists are as a matter of fact
there are gods in Lovecraft stories
they're just not the kind of God that
we're used to thinking of right um and I
don't know if we want them to be gods or
or not um I mean Lovecraft is um so
let's back this up again so Lovecraft is
influenced by po right many other
authors as well and a lot of those
authors themselves are in effect
engaging with philosophy and natural
science in their
Works PO is is conscious of quite a few
people and Lovecraft is you know living
he's not living in Boston right but you
could say that he's in a Bostonian New
yorkian Providence orbit as far as like
learned literature and stuff like that
so you know he's he's familiar with
people who are very popular at the time
like Herbert Spencer right the the great
utilitarian and positivist philosopher
that really nobody reads anymore but was
kind of a big deal back then um he you
know he knows n he knows a number of
other
interesting uh philosophers as well he
knows about you know um sort of in in
basic terms like the the history of of
ideas he's not looking he's not doing
philosophy to do philosophy he's not
like saying oh I want to I want to take
these ideas from this thinker and
allegorize them into a story he's sort
of like Philip K dick in that respect
right who's read quite a lot and he
hasn't just read philosophy as such as a
as an isolated discipline he's read you
know some some religion stuff and some
literature some poetry I mean Lovecraft
is very into poetry uh as was po um as
were a lot of people back then and
Lovecraft also learns things from
talking with with other people you know
so one of his big correspondents was uh
Robert Howard right and uh we can talk
about um the influence of some of these
other thinkers on on Howard as as well
too right um Lovecraft had like an
incredible network of people that he was
writing to um and who were writing to
him so yeah uh who framed the Socratic
method Lovecraft love detective fiction
I see a lot of influence from Victorian
times like Doyle but more importantly
POS r
rization i wonder about wild satire of
supernatural detective fiction yeah I
don't I don't know if wild had a big
influence on on Lovecraft that way and
he's he's you know he does have some of
the tropes we could say of detective
fiction right but it's within a horror
framework
so you know think about kalak culu right
we have in effect
a detective story going on what's what's
with these weird Cults you know what's
going on here um but it leads you to
this gigantic being who awakens from the
lost city of relay underneath the the
water so it's not your normal detective
fiction oh we're gonna we found the
perpetrators were going to take them
away to prison you know or or they they
hung themselves or or something like
that it's it's it is detective fiction
and actually you know somebody else who
plays with this this Trope who's a
follower of of Lovecraft August derith
right um he actually if I I mean derith
is interesting because he actually has a
detective fiction series that was so
similar to Sherlock Holmes that Arthur
Conan Doyle's estate sued derith and
lost uh his solar ponds uh stuff but he
also does have uh you know cthulu Mythos
stuff and he he monkeys around with the
Mythos he's he's doing something a bit
different but he's also really important
for keeping lovecraft's works and ideas
alive and in his admittedly second rate
um writings compared to lovecrafts
Originals um he has detectives as well
and you notice if any of you have ever
played the um
chaosium game uh kalak culu detective is
one of the like character types that you
can you can play in that because it it
figures into that
um all right uh oh Matthew's played that
i' I've never actually gotten to play it
I've only gotten to as you often do with
RPGs look at look through the rules and
catalog and stuff like that Matt says
I'd like to acknowledge HP lovecrafts
influence on metal music yeah that's
that's that's
significant um
he has furnished great themes for
musicians to explore you know you could
think of the the very song a great
instrumental by uh Metallica The kakulu
you know uh which is just a a wonderful
long song I used to play that um when I
when I played bass I had uh the song
books for the first three albums and as
well as Iron Maiden stuff and Black
Sabbath stuff off and things like that
and that was that was one of my favorite
songs to play I'd get my distortion
pedal out because it was just me and
then I would I'd play it and stuff like
that oh um Matthew asks uh which is your
favorite story I don't know if you
already said it I don't I don't have a
favorite HP Lovecraft story I would say
I have like among my favorites right and
the cats of UR is one of them that's why
I did it for this this presentation
um I mean I do like the dream quest of
unknown cth which is also in this thing
um yeah of the
others
um I mean the Dunwich Horror I would say
is is a
particularly gripping
one
um I forget the name of the one but it's
it's the one where Nar Nar holp actually
comes
to uh the society right um Henry asked
do you have a favorite film that's
inspired by Lovecraft um you know I
haven't seen the color out of space and
I hear that's pretty good um I have seen
the DWI horror which was done in the 70s
terrible I actually saw that back in in
uh the late 80s
um uh the one that had Sam Neil in it
and I'm blanking on the name was pretty
good because part of what I'm looking
for in these stories is like Lovecraft
said atmosphere is really
important and um I also want to see if
you're doing stuff you know you don't
just bring the Necronomicon in like Evil
Dead has oh it's a scary book bad bad B
book or something like that there's got
to be this sense of horror I would say
you know it's not inspired by Lovecraft
but one of the scariest movies horror
movies that I've ever seen is um Prince
of
Darkness that is really really creepy um
Event Horizon um oh in the mouth of
Madness the Sam Neil one that's that's
quite good Event Horizon is is pretty
damn creepy too in in the same kind of
way I think you gotta you gotta leave
the motivations of the evil powerful
being somewhat in the background so that
you're not quite sure what the hell's
going on or what's gonna stop them right
um so that that uh figures in and I
think you could say somebody mentioned
body wh you know the thing is not based
on a Lovecraft story it's based on
another story that is in the science
fiction Hall of Fame called who goes
there and it's a really great story and
the thing is pretty faithful to it but
the thing could be viewed also as
lovecraftian as well right
um oh somebody did pikmin's model
recently that is
interesting
um yeah that that could be a good one it
I mean it's it's it this is a whole big
conversation we could have and I'm
actually G to have to get get going
because we're going to watch the game in
just a bit go back to mondane reality um
it's tough to adapt certain kinds of
speculative fiction literature well to
film or TV and part of that is just you
know getting across the atmosphere
correctly adequately part of it is like
getting the
writers and the producers to stick to
the to the damn story because they
always want to like put their own spin
on it and usually they they make it bad
when they do that right they reduce it
um it's tough to to to do those those
sorts of things well you you really need
somebody who
appreciates the the work and then
there's certain things that are just
tough to do I talked about this recently
with uh Jimmy nuts we had a conversation
about um uh Philip K dicks man in the
High Castle and the use of the Oracle or
eing right the the book of changes and
we're like well how would you actually
it's it's really absolutely important in
the book but how do you get that across
in a cinematic way that people would
appreciate you know what they would end
up doing Hollywood producers is like
having the Euro stocks glow and float in
the air and then the book opens up it
like flips open but you don't want to do
all that kind of you instead
you want it you know a great movie in my
view that I haven't seen for a long time
but it's it made a huge impression on me
when I did see it that was able to get
across like the sense of threat and
Dread without doing a hell of a lot and
and making things go pretty slow was
tarov is the stalker you know not
lovecraftian but really getting that
atmospheric thing
across so um so Matt says Gomer Doro had
pikmin's model in his cabinet of curiosi
I'll have to I'll have to check that out
um that sounds quite interesting so all
right well this is a good place to to
wrap it up I didn't expect it to
actually go this long u but we we had
some great discussion so thanks to
everybody for your comments um if you
haven't read these stories you know you
can find the links below to free
versions of them they're very quick you
know very easy to to get through you
should check them out not horror stories
as such but you can uh you can
definitely get some enjoyment out of
them and I will see you all next month
not sure which story I'll be doing for
next month but I'm going to start
resuming these Sadler telling stories um
and so I hope all of you have a great
evening morning afternoon wherever you
happen to be and I'll see you next
time